a route out of lockdown phased and
gradual balancing lives with livelihoods
but the questions for our government is
when and how across government we have
been thinking about different settings
whether that's in the workplace on
public transport in schools or outdoors
what sorts of steps might members of the
public families or employers take to
ensure that those settings are as safe
as possible the government is talking to
businesses to learn how more can reopen
thank you food staff and customers safe
but businesses say they need clearer
guidance more clarity on the planned
exit strategy you've written to the
government what do you want Boris
Johnson to do for business really clear
guidance for businesses how they be open
and also to see an integrated plan
between the way that businesses will
slowly reopen and the other aspects of
infrastructure that businesses rely on
so those are things like transport or
childcare or schools businesses need all
of those things to open in there in an
overall and planned fashion for us to be
able to slowly get our economy going the
social distancing rule is one of the
biggest challenges the World Health
Organization says it should be at least
one meter but here in the UK it's twice
that length at 2 meters reducing it
could have a massive impact because many
shops restaurants and offices just are
big enough to reopen with a 2 meter rule
still in place two meters indoors
doesn't really make a great deal more
sense I mean the the clinical evidence
the experimental evidence really speaks
to the safety of the 1 meter radius
indoors all our lives have been impacted
by the virus and changes to the way we
work will be long-lasting returning
workers might be expected to take their
own temperatures before leaving home
on public transport commuters might have
to wear face masks and work start times
are likely to be staggered to avoid rush
hour build ups that make social
distancing difficult at work
temperatures may be taken again hand
sanitizers and even PPE in some cases
may need to be used staggered meal
breaks and closed canteens will enable
social distancing office workers are
unlikely to return to a normal workplace
for quite some time
with possibly many more months of
working from home so this is the new
reality for me and my colleagues here at
Sky when we come to work
we're scanned for our temperature with a
thermal imaging camera if our
temperatures are normal
then we're allowed to walk onto the
campus but if they're too high then
we're asked to go home next week the
Prime Minister is expected to give more
details for his exit strategy after six
weeks in lockdown many of us will emerge
to a working landscape that has been
completely transformed and is likely to
stay that way for quite some time
Ashish Joshi scans